PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and this is AI
Simplified where we
learn to make your data useful.
In the previous
episodes, we learned
how to create data sets in
Vertex AI and trained machine
learning model using auto ML.
In this video, we help
our friends at Fuel Symbol
build custom machine
learning models.
Their team of machine
learning experts
have decided to write
their own training
code to predict the fuel
efficiency of a vehicle.
Join me as I walk them through
the different ways in which you
can run custom
training in Vertex AI.
And finally, we will kick off
our training job in the console
and see how it's done.
Now what do we need to
create a custom job?
Before we submit any of the
custom jobs to Vertex AI,
we need to create a Python
training application or custom
container to write the training
code and the dependencies.
There are pre-built
containers to run our code
if we write our training
application in Python
using TensorFlow, scikit-learn,
XG Boost or PyTorch.
If you are using
pre-built containers,
then you can just
provide the path
to the training package
in Cloud storage.
You can also build your
own custom containers,
if you wish to.
And in that case, you
provide a location
to the container from
your container registry
or your artifact registry.
If you're not sure whether
to use pre-built or custom
containers, then check out
the link I've included below.
In both cases, you would need
a folder within Cloud storage
bucket to put your model
output artifacts into.
When running custom
training jobs on Vertex AI,
we can also make use of Vertex's
hyperparameter tuning service.
If you're not familiar
with hyperparameters,
they are variables that
govern the process of training
your models, such as batch
size or number of hidden layers
in a deep neural network.
In hyperparameter tuning
jobs, the Vertex AI
creates trials of
your training job
with different sets
of hyperparameters,
and then searches for the best
combination of hyperparameters
across a series of those trials.
Now to run the training,
you need compute resources.
It can be either single
node or multiple worker
pools for distributed training.
This is also the
step where you would
select the type of
machines, the CPUs, the disk
size, and the disk type, and
the accelerators, such as GPUs.
And once that
training is done, we
need the trained
module as an endpoint
to be served for predictions.
In Vertex AI, we can do that by
using pre-built containers that
are supported runtime such
as TensorFlow, scikit-learn,
PyTorch.
Or you can also build
your own custom container
that is stored in container
registry or artifact registry.
Of course, if you just
need the module artifacts
to be downloaded, then you can
skip these steps altogether.
Or you can just use the
model for batch predictions.
Now that we have the basic
understanding of our custom
training choices,
let's help Fuel Symbol
train and sell a custom
model that predicts the fuel
efficiency of a vehicle.
We will be using TensorFlow
to build this model.
And then we'll package
our training code
in a Docker container.
So let's see.
In the Google Cloud
console, before we begin,
make sure to enable the
Vertex AI API Compute Engine
and Container Registry APIs.
In this example, we
will use Notebooks
to create the code for
our Docker container.
But you can use any environment
you like to do this.
Create a new notebook instance
with the latest version
of TensorFlow Enterprise.
For this particular demo,
I am training without GPUs.
But depending on your use case,
choose GPUs if you need them.
Now that our
instance is created,
let's open the JupyterLab
and navigate to the terminal
window in our notebook.
For the purpose of this demo,
we will use the training code
that already exists
in TensorFlow Docs
to predict the fuel
efficiency of a vehicle.
It uses the auto MPG data
set from Kaggle to predict,
and I've included the
link below to this page.
What we will do here is
we submit the training job
to Vertex AI by putting our
training called in a Docker
container and pushing the
container to Google Container
Registry.
Using this approach,
we can train a model
built with any framework.
Now, our first step is
to create a Docker file.
This Docker file uses one of
the deep learning container
TensorFlow Enterprise
Docker images.
Now the deep learning
containers on Google Cloud
come with many common machine
learning and data science
frameworks preinstalled.
The one we're using here
includes TensorFlow Enterprise,
Pandas, scikit-learn,
and others.
Now after downloading
that image,
this Docker file sets
up the entry point
for our training code.
And we haven't created
these files yet.
But we will do that now.
Before that, we need
a Cloud Storage bucket
to export our trained
TensorFlow model into.
Vertex AI will then
use this bucket
to read our imported
model assets,
and to deploy the model.
Now for our model code, let's
create a trainer directory
and a train.py file.
We would add our training
code to the train.py file.
Here, I have adapted the
code from the TensorFlow
docks for the model to
predict fuel efficiency
for the vehicles.
Now if you're interested
in using the same code,
follow the codelab
that's linked below.
We need to make sure
we update the bucket
variable with the name
of the storage bucket
that we just created earlier.
Now we need to build and
test the container locally.
Let's run the container
within our notebook
to see if it is
working correctly.
Now, it's building now.
And now that it is built,
let's run this container.
There it is.
Working fine.
In a production
environment, training
will likely take longer,
which is why you would
want to run it on the Cloud.
Now let's see how to do that.
Now we push it to Google
Container Registry
so Vertex AI can access it.
With our container pushed
to Container Registry,
we are now ready to kick off
a custom model training job.
Now we go to the
training in Vertex AI
and select No managed
data sets since a data
set is being pulled from the
source in our model code.
Now Vertex AI gives
us two options
for training the models.
With auto ML, we can
train high quality models
with minimal effort and
machine learning expertise.
And we covered this in
our previous episodes.
So check them out.
Now here, we are
using custom training.
Give the model a name and
in container settings,
we have two options.
Now pre-built containers
support PyTorch, scikit-learn,
TensorFlow and XG Boost.
It requires us to
package and upload
our application code and
dependencies to a Cloud storage
bucket.
Now because we have our
own custom container
on Google Container Registry,
we will select Custom Container
here, which supports not just
the common machine learning
frameworks, but also non
machine learning dependencies,
libraries, and binaries.
Now we provide our image URL
and our Cloud storage bucket.
And we will see hyperparameter
tuning in later episodes.
So let's leave this unchecked
for now and continue.
In Compute and Pricing, we
set up a standard machine
since this model trains quickly.
But you're welcome to experiment
with larger machine types
and GPUs if you like.
Just remember that
if you use the GPUs,
you will need to use a GPU
enabled base container image.
The Prediction
Container section is
where we specify how we would
like to serve our model.
Now here we use
pre-built containers.
And we provide the path to
our Cloud storage bucket.
And, we're ready for training.
We can check to see the
training in progress.
This could take some time.
I have fast forwarded
the process here for you.
Now that our model
is trained, we
need to deploy it to an
endpoint to make predictions.
Now give it a name and
since this is a demo,
we will just leave the
traffic split at 100%,
and enter 1 for minimum
number of compute nodes.
Depending on the use case,
you can set the maximum number
of nodes for autoscaling when
the traffic on the endpoint
is high.
I'm selecting a standard
machine type here.
Pick the one that makes sense
for your use case, and deploy.
Deploying the endpoint
will take a few minutes.
And when it is done, we can
see it in our Endpoint tab.
Now that our
endpoint is deployed,
we can start making predictions.
We will get predictions
on our trained
model from a Python notebook
using the Vertex AI Python SDK.
But you can get predictions
from any environment you like.
So I'm back in our
notebook instance
and creating a Python 3
notebook from the launcher.
Now we install
the Vertex AI SDK.
Then add a cell
to import the SDK
and create a reference to the
endpoint we just deployed.
Replace the endpoint
and the project
ID with our values of the
endpoint and project ID.
And then finally,
we make a prediction
to our endpoint
with some test data.
And there's our predicted value.
With that, we've helped
our friends at Fuel Symbol
train a custom model
using Vertex AI.
We provided the training
code in custom container,
and used TensorFlow model here.
But you can train a model
built with any framework using
custom containers.
Then we deployed
the TensorFlow model
using pre-built containers.
And we finally created
a model endpoint
and generated a prediction.
In the next video, we will build
a vision model using auto ML.
In the meantime, let's
continue our discussion
in the comments below.
And don't forget to
like and subscribe.